boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about human
AI hybrid collaboration we have an epic
group joining us today I'm super excited
we're already talking about building
tools maximizing humanity's collective
and individual capabilities saving us
vast amounts of cognitive labor
extending our memory in all areas of
life super pumped to have joining us on
the show we have Jacob Cole who is the
co-founder and CEO of idea flow and a
former MIT collective intelligence
researcher then next we have Monty Kozma
he is a physicist an ex lawyer
management consultant and polymath and
lastly we have Jack Bafa who is a
Stanford grad in computer science and
anthropology and an entrepreneur super
excited that we are going to have us
talking with Ford people at the table
and simulation I'm jacked this is super
fun thanks for joining us on the show
everyone so Jack you you mentioned that
a book on physics that really was
accessible to you earlier yeah I called
again yeah it was really interesting and
I have to remember the name cuz that's I
just think of it as the quantum book but
it's quantum mechanics the theoretical
minimum and it's by Leonard Susskind
Stanford professor Wow and so you think
this really made physics like it was
explained to complex physics in a way
that you understood and appreciated yeah
I mean it's like quantum mechanics is
just a very like difficult to grasp
field so this was like the first book I
had read that like actually explained it
to someone at least with exactly the
amount of knowledge I had which was like
very basic mathematical knowledge and
pretty much nothing else so yeah it was
like perfect for that audience I thought
yeah and I worked really well for that
what was the name one more time I was
quantum mechanics the theoretical
minimum what's it quantum mechanics the
theoretical minimum
hashtag book Leonard Susskind new line
relates to Jack Bafa thanks sure
I'll see you guys what I just did yeah
what'd you do
yeah home dump pump to share this yeah
wrote down these notes in my thought
stream yeah and we're gonna have a focus
happened yeah there we go
I'm point and what is a thought stream
my thought stream is a giant text file
historically where I write all of mine
put it even more central it's a bonus
everything probably even more yeah like
right there and now just hold it yeah
like that
yes okay cool and now teach us about
this thought stream yeah so I thought
stream is how I've been keeping minutes
for many years now and they've been
building progressively better tools to
make it easier to do this this is the
latest iteration but I just prepend new
notes at the top
whenever I have them and write them down
and then if I ever want to find them
again though I need a hashtag so I add a
hashtag book and I can see by clicking
on that a list of all the books I've
ever written down and secondly I connect
these things to various people such as
tamati like Monty loves Vernor Vinge and
especially woken deepness in the sky so
I connected that clicked on Monty Kozma
you can see all the dirt I have she's
not a lot of dirt actually in that case
but in other cases they have like a good
lead a bunch earlier I guess I guess
relevant the conversation at hand today
I've got a 1-1 cool example here which
is augmenting human cognition this is a
book by by Doug Engelbart by the way
Doug Engelbart anyone heard the name
Doug Engelbart in this room I've heard
it how are you
No so doug engelbart is like whether it
can you know camera yeah you're you're
pretty close there you go
yeah you're closer so i maybe even prior
to doug engelbart i think it's important
to talk about this Ari I try to put it
over his face since that's what it's
gonna be you want to and if you can
bring it even closer to the camera and
then put it in the center of the screen
but okay let's let's for a moment let's
yeah just for a moment because I think
this is this is really important to
begin unpacking because your boy over
here is using Evernote and your boys got
like three thousand notes that he's made
over the last five years okay
so it's just this interesting little
Universal synergy that Alex k10 drops
you so gently into my life and now this
manner by the name of Jacob Kohl's like
oh I have this epic note-taking thoughts
dream device and way of cataloging all
of this information in ways that are
extremely able to query later and this
is awesome yeah so all right
teach us about this because this is
obviously really interesting and it's
really applicable to people that love to
take notes yeah so very very very
high-level comment I think like Ted
Nelson said it best Ted Nelson Nelson is
most famously as the inventor of the
hyperlink he had a very very cool vision
still hasn't been built yet but he said
that much of his life is tied up in
manuscript handling in roughly and yep
he hates categories like he hates having
to stick notes in a single category
because that's not how things are that's
not how things are in his brain it's
just like a constraint of the physical
world and he's like you know suddenly
these are computers yet why does the
software that we use on computers look
like paper it's like in with all the
constraints and limitations of paper
instead it should be much closer to how
our mind is
in my mind things have many categories
things are deeply intertwined gold and
other famous Ted Nelson line doing go I
want to enjoy things in the external
world like I do in my mind because
otherwise I won't remember how things
are entangled if you a little while
after and secondly a benefit of
externalizing my cognition is it can
become a shared cognition and I can
really remember things I never knew if I
share my brain room okay I can
externalize my cognition and then I can
make my cognition collective cognition
we can then okay now now I'll do my
little quick big history okay Jesus
humans have now this incredible gift of
life on this rock opening the star and
we have built civilization on this idea
of collective learning over time that is
an epic technology that made humans take
off yes yes and so this what you said
earlier about spending so much time
handling manuscripts is hilarious to me
because I do that and it is it is time
for us to find the technical solution
for us to be able to get this cognition
externalize it and then make it very
easy for us to collectively collaborate
especially as a lot of the things that
we aim to discuss are at this edge of
knowledge and so if we want to
collectively push the boundaries at the
edge of knowledge we need the right tool
to be able to push us out yes most
effectively yeah and just as a quick
side comment as you say that what pops
into my head is something I've always
wanted which is did you ever play if you
do game that had like a fog of war or a
dark area on the edge of the map totally
and it's like the first
played Starcraft I was pretty young but
my hands are sweating so much that I had
to put a tissue over the mouse or rather
my uncle's mouse and my uncle was like
yo and luckily there were tissues nearby
because we keep tissues by our computers
it's all different and so anyway um I
always have been enchanted by this idea
of exploring world maps like world maps
without a darkened have this very
enchanting feel of it and what I feel
oftentimes separated from it is the
great mystery of things especially in
civilization like it's suddenly I'm
reminded of when I'm in like a small
cabin in a huge rainstorm that's when I
start to sense oh man this is like we're
just a tiny thing in this vast universe
I really feel it we're looking up at the
stars in a place that doesn't have light
pollution and you're just looking up and
there's so many stars and so many
planets orbiting those stars can
potentially so much life yes and so that
sense of wonder like escapes me
sometimes and it bothers me that I don't
have like external aether to help me
remember that's a different time oh you
remember example demand an invading
stuff but that's why you're making the
external it's right now yes and I think
there's lots this is like a much deeper
rabbit hole to be got into and how far
we can go with that but my point was
let's see what was the thing exactly
feeling kind of like dwarfed by the ego
in our cabin WD previous thing pre prior
to cabin the collective intelligence and
pushing the edge of knowledge yes okay
so I also feel that way I also felt that
same type of awe when I first played
Starcraft and had the fog of the level
of you world map and which are areas for
those that don't know that haven't
played games at a fog of war fog of war
is an area fog of war is a weird term it
just means parts of the map that you
can't see but in the beginning it's very
small because most your Maps not
explored and then then it's like to joke
you really get that cabin feeling again
of like you're in a vast darkness this
is making me want like Google Maps to
implement fog of war
it'd be really interesting and
completely useless but this is our new
revolutionary feature right alongside
Google now it would it would be a really
good motivation to do that yeah that's
like when you have an update there's an
area like you'd see which areas really
haven't been updated in a long time
you're like oh dang there could be like
I don't know yeah it would be
interesting to see it just in terms of
like my own my own history like if I had
the data on everywhere I've ever been
with an IP connection and an IP address
at least right it could show me where
have I been
and how frequently yeah and then show me
all the places that I've never been I
mean I kind of know that I've never been
to Sri Lanka but like you know some of
them are obvious but actually this area
of San Francisco right well it's like
it's like the mapping I want to do in
the intellectual mapping told we were
talking about earlier about books right
I want to know what are all the books
that you've read what are all the books
on your shelf that you want to read
I want to map that against mine because
that gives us connection points right
you could do that with maps if I had a
map of everywhere I've been and I
overlaid my map with yours I would know
that you've never been to Burning Man
right or maybe you've been by but maybe
you know I don't know when you yeah that
would be really interesting with like
points in common that people had like I
am the only man versus an or all right
both would be revealing you're saying is
that like okay but this is a beautiful
idea oh my god that's so cool it's gonna
it's gonna all do graphics I'm not even
looking at that game now but I don't
even have to get back to this the
awesome so I said a good point which is
which is yo this is so cool
when Monty looks at Allen's bookshelf
what he sees is the intellectual
territory Allen is covered has exactly
things we could talk to him about like
who is the guy that you design ladies I
am
yeah geopolitics right fellow Texan yeah
and so that's so you can see like this
overlapping what this is fundamentally
is is seeing this overlapping point on
your intellectual map and that's what
that's what the book show you know
what's also interesting is showing up at
someone's house and you realize you know
none of the books but it's like very
fascinating to see that right yeah
they've constructed themselves and
actually that's okay and so this is like
their house right now the killer the
killer a pollute the killer application
of this technology of course is dating
ah I want today I mean seriously the the
first I have very limited dating
experience but I got I was I got
divorced after being married for like 20
almost 30 years and and and I really
latched on to this this great girl
actually had lunch with her today only
because of the books on her shelf like
she had Richard Posner's economic
analysis of law and she had cars Lords
translation of Aristotle's politics and
it was like has these books like
completely out of nowhere it's no no
girl in San Francisco has those books
you have to go to Texas find it a girl
those kinds of tastes usually anyway but
that's the kind of thing if you could
actually like find out just what a
person's curious
and look for those connection points I
mean that's where like the rich like the
rich intellectual life rich friendships
all that stuff in my mind at least maybe
is in my real life that's well right you
don't want too much overlap right
because like you want to be with friends
like that teaching you things to bring
new things into your life I mean you
know it's cool that we've both read
Peters ion but like you guys have it and
we hate you know we can talk all about
you we talked all night about
geopolitics and you know the energy
industry and how the transformation of
the world is gonna happen in the next
you know five 10 years cuz we're on
sextet irrelevant topic you got to see
what's on my screen right now guys so so
so check this out check this out so just
call me angle Burke say angle things but
anyway here's Doug Engelbart and I'm
gonna hit jump legs like kind of like
slap except for my brain and you can see
the book augmenting human cognition and
now I click on Doug Engelbart this is a
book that I highly enjoy yep and I click
on more Center ok I click on it Doug
Engelbart and now you can see that he's
connected to a bunch of stuff and he's
connected the mouse he was the inventor
of the mouse and he's connected to the 5
button anglo-boer keyboard which is a
much better community communication
alright computer input device but let's
click on the mouse the mouse was also
connected to I do I do is connected to
my friend each hang and also this guy
Gavin McDermott who apparently has found
his life's passion in a deep way and I'm
supposed to hashtag meet at some point
he's connected to world papper but an
each hang is connected to Jacob and
Jacob is connected to all the different
this is the short answer is when I want
it to happen like if I said at sign Alan
on one of my things it would give me the
option to share it in your knowledge
exactly so you need to you need to have
this multi-tiered privacy things you
could have it maybe a public one you got
one for various groups you're in and
then you got your private one and what's
cool is that everyone has sort of a
unique set of data and private
organizations as they're part of so
everyone's confluence of these knowledge
gaps maybe over time and space is
actually different so even if they
themselves like aren't any smarter than
someone else or aren't any more clever
than someone else's this just really
makes visual how our different life
experiences enable this creativity
looping this back a couple of steps to
whole fog of war thing and the
intellectual map that hasn't been
covered in that civilization because
they're slowly expanding
here now we get to leverage these tools
these human hybrid tools can help us
with this collective learning push it
faster
I guess yes to all points and in truth
improv style yes and the thing that
gives me that it was starting up to say
it the very beginning of this I said
they always wanted is a video game where
I could go online and explore the world
map but this world map was not a map of
land and places that are made up but it
was instead a web of interconnected
ideas that were laid out on a 2d map
Vienna
you can walk around this world and as a
meta comic about these visions it's so
great that we're connecting now it would
have been great if we connected long ago
and there's probably ten more people who
have had the same vision yes and they
are feeling intellectually lonely right
now somewhere and it's only by ad hoc
random coincidences chance introductions
and a systematic things this happens
we're living in the Wild West Allen
we're living in the Wild West things
only happen by chaos and this is why so
many people have existential crises
about doing things like making college
this is because they're like oh dang if
I make this college decision I don't
know all the implications of what's
gonna happen and it's gonna literally be
all these people that I know I can't
tell for better or for worse and the
worst things can become good and stuff
like that and it's largely because of
these serendipitous connections between
people and between ideas and so if there
were systems that were in place in the
world that systematically connected all
the people that really should be
connected I would be so much less
worried about about this and there's so
many industries that would be absolutely
like ended if like like recruiting as an
industry like matching people to the
right projects to be working on is one
such much stuff saying matching
co-founders to each other perhaps is
dating all these things would be like
dramatically solved if you could have a
really good connector a really good
super connector like Alex kitchen except
scaled and massively
do you think that having like a sort of
I guess it's a hybrid knowledge map
system but integrated between the way
people map knowledge to form connections
is kind of what I'm imagining here do
you think that would actually go to like
reduce the sort of chaotic nature of the
world that you were describing with like
what will the consequences of my actions
be do you think it would have that
result or mainly just like foster
connections that you might not have made
otherwise or there's two comments there
yeah so when talking about creative
noise creative noise is an idea that I
really like it's just like okay throwing
ideas together maybe throwing like like
I love staring at clouds and drawing
what I see because I can trace a lot
better than that can draw and if I like
see it cloud I can trace a car take a
photo of a cloud or something I can
trace all kinds of way more impressive
pictures in that house than they can
drop from scratch
yeah in general come up with more
creative ideas and this is just like a
noise generator for you watching but and
in that case you you want to have some
chaos and then on the other end it's
like okay meeting intellectual soulmates
it's like you meet someone you're like
oh dang where were you the last six
years and that's something you wouldn't
[Music]
agree the last six years and it's like
it's like the work the world's
productivity would be so much better I
think you just like got all those people
together and that's something you super
want to decrease the chaos of and like
share there's gonna be certain
differences connections that were missed
but it's at least you know I probably
got five out of the top ten people I
should be meeting in the world even if I
live in Macedonia I never left my
hometown
and I like how you also make it super
clear that there is so much potential
for us to be able to push the edge of
knowledge in ways that have yet to be
discovered because we haven't applied
yet
and again the visualization be surface
versus the visualization is the project
might just freak out when you see right
now do you want to forget
no lunch me it's not even my project
like you want to see you can go on your
computer right now to wiki dot polyframe
and Holly Lukey dot frame frame dot and
then it's a it's a dot me domain so
probably free about me Oh Polly free
public art dot me sir a why no no sorry
dot right now dot Emmy okay Oh God this
is called wiki galaxy this is a friend
of mine wiki you freaked out
media articles 500 somatic it's not even
wiki planet flicky galaxy is beyond
oh there's nothing's gonna it's a lot of
galaxies so if you start zooming up this
is Wikipedia and they zoomed out an
article he galaxy's a 3d web experiment
that visualizes Wikipedia as a galactic
web of information he's a hundred
thousand of 2014's most popular articles
all clustered with hyperlinks in this
world with the pedia articles are stars
yes interests or nebulous name is Owen
he works at IBM last I checked IBM
Research yeah yeah but this is a side
part of his side-project for years and
years in college and stuff but we click
on a node up comes a nebula what
anything this is just watch that zoom
and oh you could just scroll in with
yours oh it's a 3d rewrapped
visualization and it actually runs
pretty fast when you're not live
streaming at yo so click on some stuff
and you'll explore some webs like let's
zoom in he's gonna get way cooler when
you click on some notes and you can even
do fly through mode with the arrow keys
and you turn that on so you can just
scroll around a bit Northumberland yeah
and then you can see what it's connected
to you on the right hand side I think
you can click on one of those things
like I love want to something look on
that right hand alright yeah ok any of
them I love white I love white
yeah you can see that and it's a goal oh
yeah just you can click on any of those
interesting yeah oh and then oh so
interesting so this is this is what it's
like when you go on to
pedia and when you click on that first
and then you yeah right now we're doing
it in a spaceship yeah you've also
eliminated a lot of information you've
eliminated essentially all the
in-between words what is and you've got
the links but that's what like from one
point of view that's kind of what you
care about like well which ideas link to
each other and you know it's a different
it's a different process it's a
different kind of engagement when you're
looking for connections between things
it's a bit of like a trade of breadth
for depth kind of yeah your instead of
exploring one time she's like search
right searches search it like our whole
world is as has been you know take it
over by Google over the last you know
couple yeah decades well you know but
the but the point of Google and and
anything like it is it's all very search
based but you know search is not
something that it's very useful for one
type of you know research and engagement
activity but like there's a lot of times
what it's not I mean if I have one of
the problems I spent a lot of years of
my life attacking is how do we
categorize information so I've got a
wealth of information how do I actually
put it into into groups that are
sensible for my particular purpose and
then make decisions on those groups
rather than having to look at a million
items can I look at a thousand items
that have been grouped effectively right
those are very very powerful problems
for powerful tools for solving massive
massive problems of organizing
information and you know what search is
completely irrelevant remarried about 99
percent irrelevant to solving those
kinds of problems if there nobody invest
in that I mean everyone's investing in
search and then how do you saw
advertising to people against that which
going on yes but I mean as just an aside
I mean the attention based advertising
economy pays for all these amazing tools
that we get to just use for free so you
know yeah how much value is created just
by the fact that we have a Google search
engine or a Gmail you know email
application or or Bing for that matter
right I mean whatever whatever it is I
heard somebody use Bing as a verb the
other day I don't know what that was
about it was it was a politician it's
too complex my first reaction is it's
too complex actually you know search is
one-dimensional you get a list of
results and you look through the list
and it's not as useful to dimensions is
way more useful for our brains to
comprehend depending on what you're
trying to do you're trying to do but
imagine if you if you could do a search
and you could actually have it organized
instead of just a linear list of results
if those results were grouped like okay
well you know here's a category where
like if I search for baseball well
here's all the stuff around the history
of the game baseball here's results that
are around you know shopping for
baseball related products here's you
know baseball cards which is its own
thing here's a group which is you know
baseball used as a metaphor
for you know sexual engagement right
earlier like you know you've got you
know you know they have been explored
it's just that it's never been
commercialized yeah I mean out there
with the tenex ATT the NEX don't know
that they exist anymore there's a whole
pile of frickin awesome tech companies
and tools that like were the diamond we
need to resurrect them yeah well we were
doing this in there in the context of a
lot so like I ran one of my previous
lives
I ran Procter & Gamble's acquisition of
Gillette like big fifty two billion
dollar acquisition and would be I do
some big projects it'll be if you heard
me if you ever need fundraising would be
sure you know this is the funny be
simple but yes approx animals
acquisition of Gillette right ok and so
we had to deal with I was at the time
doing antitrust competition law and we
had to deal with the regulators in DC
and around the world who wanted to
figure out what is the effect of
combining these businesses because a
couple of businesses so they both talked
to me gamble and Gillette were both in
deodorants and they were both in dental
care as one owned crest one owned oral-b
right so you have to figure out okay
well what's gonna be the impact on
competition of all these markets all
around the world and so the process
involves gathering because the
government has the power to repeal this
to do their investigation they want
every document from these companies that
relates to competition and like okay
well like
how much is this you know well it turns
out that and I'm sure the numbers have
scaled up since then but you know at the
time the cost for each persons who
documents that you want to get their
email their paper documents everything
just just to get the email and the
documents off their computer and look at
them cost about between fifty and
seventy thousand dollars per person and
the government wants to look at
documents from two to three hundred
people
Wow in cases like that so massive costs
and you know so one of the things I did
was I actually designed kind of engineer
a process around this and then built
technology into the process and what we
did was this technology we had this
brilliant brilliant engineer he actually
is teaching his stuff up in Seattle Mail
skip Walter took some technology out of
Battelle National Labs which had
developed some of this stuff for you
know spy type stuff you know looking at
Intel that would take take a document
what it was figure out which words it
would grammatically parts that figure
out which words are used as nouns and
then all the words that look like
they're nouns we would treat those as a
concept and then we would use those
concepts to create like a fingerprint
and organize documents into clusters and
put them put them all on on a
two-dimensional like spiderweb graph
it's amazing and it looks a lawful lot
like what you're doing very similar idea
it was called a tenex yeah I'm not sure
that he can ATT yeah they were acquired
by FTI Consulting
here in here in the Bay Area and you
know like like all big consulting firms
I don't think they effectively took that
technology forward is a sad story and
got like several sparks one of the
things you said so a 10x hashtag related
company then I hit angle brackets Monte
Kozma and and put down skip Walter
because you need to meet skip skip
Walter and I'm gonna say hashtag meet
cool and where is he like the founder of
the company he was one of the cofounders
um awesome so alright so what I just did
guys is I have a very small green so if
we can see we're very very small green
and so I made a lot of people but I want
to help them or like but mine is extra
small at this way and so what is a 10x
hashtag related company meaning it's a
company relating to my company and
actually could another tag hashtag
related project which doesn't even
restrict itself to companies but it's
connected it with angled brackets which
is this new symbol that I kind of means
relates to that's how you read it it's
like relates to Monty Cosmo relates to
skip Walter and it creates a backlink as
well so if I can now click on Monty
Cosmo you can see that Monty Cosmo is
connected to a deepness in the sky and
to attend X and the fact that there's a
backlink they're super nice because that
means if ever go to Monte Carlo I can
see this note even though that note was
many pages ago in my thought stream yeah
so thoughts streaming I would say is
something that is just a way of taking
notes it doesn't really matter what
tools you're using you can put a text
file you can do it on paper it just
means not worrying about categorization
first like the issue that I have
Evernote is I've got to think about
where I'm gonna put something generally
and there are ways around this by using
tagging but I'm unsatisfied by them
because what I really want to do is just
dump all my notes as low striction
medium possible onto a piece of paper
and then add a few tags really quickly
and that workflow is just practically
impossible at Evernote yeah I'd almost
separate it from note-taking even as a
concept because very important my uses
for Evernote would be almost disjoint
with my uses for a tool like this
because there are certain cases where
categories make a lot of sense like if
I'm taking notes for a lecture or a
class or something I want to say
here's the class or like notes for a
project but maybe even within a project
if I like you we were talking about this
at one point and you mentioned friction
being like a big point because if I'm
taking notes or I have a note for like a
project or something that I want to like
you know remember for a certain purpose
I don't want to have to fumble through
my Evernote to find like oh well where
was this project in my notebook or did I
write about this project in some
unrelated notebook or yes like that no
irrelevant to finding the information
just about the information in one yeah
exactly
so yeah I would always just like anytime
that I wanted to just jot down stuff I
feel like this would be a good like
medium for that as almost separated from
note-taking as a concept yes yes so
note-taking so by the way I'm an
obsessive keeper of like lists of ideas
and quotes and books and people I meet
but I do not take a lot of notes in
class I just try to understand and pay
attention in the lecture and maybe drop
there are few scribbles put the class
and so yeah yeah it's not and it's
really a very separate problem and you
know Evernote and OneNote and stuff can
do a great job with those things and I
don't want to try to replace them I
think they do it fine and your even
paper notebooks are pretty fine for that
yeah I love sharing my notes that I do
take good notes on something I'm like
you know as long as I put so much effort
in this they might as well to share are
some people to help them and that's the
one we can you take digital notes I'm
also obsessed with creating class
rookies like almost
either I do this on a Google Sites or
just a Google document mapper to
reasonable domain name and for a bunch
of classes I took at MIT and stuff I
just would make it Google site I had all
my notes or you know other people can
add to it but I wouldn't actually return
to a couple of other points parks
I got I wimpin sparks I also did I just
wanted to see if you wanted to explain
I very much do I want to catch these
three sparks and I'll show the point
where some of the bees get back okay
smart boy
so Monty made a super relevant point a
moment ago which was like you can just
take all the nouns or named entities in
a document and extract them and this
creates of pre an almost unique
fingerprint for this document and one of
the profound ideas I picked up from
studying a bit of category theory was
yes and I'm gonna get to that as well so
so the first thing is is just like idea
from category theory enough which is
this somewhat obscure branch of meta
mathematics that is more popular in the
UK in Europe than in the US but it's
basically the mathematics of figuring
out when different mathematical
disciplines are actually the same
mathematical discipline and some of
course in front of correspondences
between these disciplines so that you
can apply learning from one discipline
to another discipline when you discover
like one concept is isomorphic it Maps
directly on to another discipline okay
well wait a second I can apply this over
here the first discipline but one of the
principles of this is things are defined
not by their names permanently but what
they are related to it the topology are
they exist in the nature of those
relationships not just the topology but
also the types of the nature of the
relationships but even if you just look
at the topology of say like this applies
to all kinds of things in art
mathematical theorems like in totally
relates I have an example I was on a
flight here and in fact it was right
after we spoke a couple of days ago I
was flying here from Texas and I was
sitting there on the plane screwing
around with with thought stream yeah
right and I just was like
stream-of-consciousness ideas and I had
been reading a book about the history of
tcp/ip
and you know the sawtooth and buffer
bloat like the problem of buffer bloat
and it like it hit me buffer bloat is
what I am suffering and what I
almost every human is suffering with
their email and there's a there's
there's some explanation to it but the
point was this was the perfect example
of what you were just saying it's
there's these concepts of
acknowledgement and exponential fall off
and buffer blow and how do you solve
that the the problem where buffer bloat
came from so if you have a router and
you've got you know incoming traffic
because you're browsing the web or
whatever and if you're sending up a
large file and and then you're
continuing to browse you know you're
sending the file in the background what
happens or you have multiple users on
the network doing this what happens is
okay it's funny because it's all driven
by economics memory dot really cheap you
know you can't buy a memory stick that's
like less than a gigabyte and so if
you're Cisco you're building a router
you want to just put a little memory in
there for a buffer while you stick in a
gigabyte okay so if you got a gigabyte
buffer because it's the smallest
cheapest remember you can put it in well
your router is gonna just stack up all
this traffic and if it can't get it out
right because you're doing some giant
file send that's fine but it interacts
in a very negative way with my web
browsing that I'm trying to do because
what happens is I asked for a page and
when I get the data I send a packet back
acknowledgment tiny just an
acknowledgment that I got it
but if that acknowledged packet going
back out is behind all this other data
transmission that's in the way it looks
like my acknowledgment is coming really
slow and what happens well if my
acknowledgment is slow to go the the
transmitting end which is doing this
tcp/ip sawtooth thing it backs off the
way it does it is it increases if it's
getting an acknowledgment packet coming
in quickly it increases the transmit
speed and if it's not it if it doesn't
get the acknowledgement it cuts the
speed in half so speed increase increase
increase drop increase increase increase
drop and what happens is because of
memory getting cheap which is like a
completely unrelated thing this pattern
that happened is that people trying to
communicate are being slowed down
absolutely unnecessary
and what hit me is this same exact
pattern it happens when we're trying to
email each other because I got a giant
you know buffer I can hold how many
gigabytes you know whatever for free
with my gmail so I have an infinite
number of emails and and they and I only
look at what's on that first screen and
if it's not just like my search it's I'm
I don't often go to screen to to figure
out what did I miss
last week or yesterday or five hours ago
depending on what my my rain of flow is
right so the cool thing about what Jakob
is saying is that you know imagine that
so there's so there's this mesh of
interconnected ideas in the realm of you
know network engineering and there's a
very similar network of meshed
interconnected ideas that Maps almost
identically in the realm of human
communication and I don't know why it
hit me maybe because I know a little bit
about both and I was reading something
and I was suffering my own buffer bloat
I don't know this is where a lot of
human creativity innovation actually
happens I don't know if we want to
automate it if we can but having tools
that can help like prompts prompt us
with ideas what do you do how do you
think about that because that's the idea
you're you're you're talking about is
these related you know related patterns
right yeah actually so let me let me add
another thing another thing our interest
at before popping just because it's
gonna be you know how I wrote down my
stack also at some point we can talk
about memory palaces for use in terms
internal to conversation to offload
cognitive effort but I just haven't been
ready turf is even faster and easier
when I can just write it down but um I'm
not that good at math it's about um the
important thing here that you just said
is something really interesting so
alright so I was having a conversation
with someone who does material science
research and she was like yeah I was
researching this this field that I
thought was brand new and my guys I
thought was brand new I think I think it
was it was the field of one-dimensional
materials I mean we barely
any-any working it's like like literally
like just changes it atoms connected to
it
and they didn't work dang I read
something really huge here and like
months later something's like you know
have you heard of these things called
molecular wires and molecular wires are
just the exact same things
one-dimensional tears if there's a huge
amount of literature on them and so the
thing is is like a human who who looks
at these two terms and especially these
two terms in context you can kind of see
that these are related fields but it's
almost impossible to like come up with
these if you don't know the search terms
and just because you don't know you're
at search terms like like there's one
thing that's a lot better than googling
something we just talk with someone
who's just thoroughly researched the
heck out of the thing and how's the map
of the whole field what's missing and
what's not there just knows in because
they know exactly not just for teaching
but for finding me the other information
because they've mapped the whole space
and they know what it isn't what it is
not as a result of jacket I'm done doing
a survey but I think that like a lot of
scientific research could be vastly sped
up and at least a lot of the connection
work that I do
could be vastly set out but I think that
I can say for sure if I even have
something like yeah it was like even if
I have only a layman's understanding of
someone's deep field you know I can
sometimes read it I just have like the
mechanical turk interface that showed me
like two different ways of phrasing
things and it would suggest hey are
these two related and I could dig into
it a little bit more effort I could say
maybe with 75% probabilities are related
or they're not related of course I
wouldn't miss the really valuable really
rare connections because I'm not an
expert but an expert looking at it could
actually say there's really really rare
connections even has a non expert in
avid connector of people I think I can I
can create a lot of value I know just
manually and with a system to augment
that connection thing it would be
ridiculous to have that that Jackson
position to it and also when you were
talking about the thing before with like
if you could have something that would
foster these connections like a person
you know
telling you in person about how this
stuff works yeah I think of like kind of
two branches there there's almost like
the the informational mapping branch
which is like a lot of what we've been
talking about with you know how you
connect ideas and stuff and you need to
build up a graph of essentially how all
this knowledge connects and that's kind
of what you can do with the you know
things that like what you were talking
about with parsing through documents to
pick out individual nouns and then
seeing how those relate but I'm
interested also in like how you could
connect a sort of almost an artificial
intelligence tool to decide for a
specific person how you would teach that
and you could almost like integrate
these things side by side and then have
like if you were now assuming like a
tool that knew or that had all of this
knowledge once you had parsed through it
and assembled it into a logical
framework then you could even start
thinking about like how do you have
something that teaches this to a person
and adapts to the specific ways a person
responds to information in response to
like getting told things and it's just a
lot of interesting areas of expansion
very interestingly enough part of the
conversation had dinner earlier with
onions tree navasana and mr Sood is and
they both geeked out about that exact
topic area of having like you know a
human teacher isn't even close to how
good a teacher that really knows
everything that you know like a buddy
that grew up with you from the womb like
you were born got an AI buddy knows
everything you've learned pretty much
and it could it could really tailor
things to you I'm also just not to not
to go down that rabbit hole which is to
fill out related resources for listeners
if no one's read Dimond age by Neal
Stephenson it's worth checking out the
primer I do have you have your diamond
age bright Neil Stevenson mm-hm you can
put your thoughts to write hashtag book
the diamond age sign Neal Stephenson
right now hashtag education
yes and so I will check the after and
yeah it proposes this in extremely
beautiful style and the second thing
that's that's relevant here is to know
about just FYI the the previous company
and you can see that that one Dennett
founder of file point the like half a
billion dollar or whatever blockchain
company his previous project was this
amazing knowledge mapping tool called
Athena where he showed the dependencies
for each thing that you wanna doing so
if you want to understand a probability
density function you know you should
probably understand a probability mass
function first or something like that
and the idea would be that if it you
could track the dependencies of
someone's master then you can really
accelerate a lot of the educational
process in that this isn't just about
education but it's also about essential
to teaching you teams to solve problems
but actually let me not when we grant
back to one previous point questions
worry about that so to do this kind of
thing you're talking about I mean I know
that like the way that you're taking
notes and taught stream and so forth
it's and and like the links in Wikipedia
it's just a link it's just this links to
that but what about the ontology what
about actually defining the way that
these objects relate so like you know
Jacob is you know my friend Jacob is my
camp mate I'm an adviser to Jacobs
company or whatever the various levels
of different relationships maybe we have
those between ideas I mean the coffee
cup is sitting on the table the coffee
cup is a container container that
contain you would it's not necessarily
an idea but I mean we have ontology it's
just easier to understand it I told you
yeah yeah so really important for it
here so they will be relationships are
important in the case of my own notes I
find that a good chunk of the time I can
get away with out
but if you actually want to be proper
about things and my my companies go
through the proper of things longer-term
you got to have labeled relationships
and it turns out that there's a syntax
called relish it's a very obscure thing
that they developed for like early
Semantic Web projects that uses these
angle brackets and the only difference
is you stick the relationship inside the
angle brackets like you could say like
Joey Ito as an as some text and then
angle brackets investor of in invest
drives inside the angle brackets then
you have idea flow yes
I really liked your formulation of you
can get it away without doing it because
that's like when I was thinking about
your question of like do you include
these sorts of like tagged relationships
versus do you just like say oh this
thing's related to this thing for human
understanding of the world the tagged
relationship is essential I feel like
because like coffee cup to table you
need to know like as the coffee cup on
the table as the coffee cup below the
table these are all like important
details but yeah then when I was
thinking about it and in terms of like
how would I design a tool that like maps
out the world and the way things in the
world relate you almost just need to tag
them and not really do much more when I
think about it I'm and I was wondering
like how important is it to include
those so this is a perfect question for
go ahead no yeah I mean that's basically
it is like I don't actually know when I
think about it where you would include
that data or like what that data would
end up doing even though it's such an
essential part of how humans understand
the world do you think like you guys are
gonna see a geophone in a bit and the
question is is what 17 Google's
knowledge graph an idea flow and
Google's knowledge graph has like all
kinds of stuff and all kinds of facts
it's really great that it knows them and
they're in the background they can like
help you link concept but you know I as
a human don't need to see most those
most of the time and if I actually saw
the might be in fact overwhelmed and so
there's a huge difference between what
you actually know if there's a way to
browse Google's knowledge graph as like
a visualization or has anyone built this
do you know
I feel like there was at one point and
then they shut down their API yeah
sounds like what Google does it's too
bad I mean this was developed by Danny
Hillis right this is what's what yeah we
need to get Danny in this room metaweb
how much you should explain okay and
then I really want to get back to that
hernia break ya know ya know we're
already there
metaweb was a project Danny Hillis who
was the founder of Thinking Machines one
of your MIT
yeah well yeah there's a great story
that I still have to get the actual
story to you between where Richard
Fineman completely intellectually
destroyed marvin minsky over a lunch
that happened there it was hilarious but
anyway yeah well anyway it's none of
that matters Danny is brilliant and he
invented the connection machine which
was I was the biggest customer back when
I was at Lockheed skunkworks yes we I
was using it for well I was part of both
I was part of the AI group and I was
also doing something like a lot of
operations research optimization type
work and I was also doing stealth
aircraft design and if I tell you
anymore I have to kill you
well we won the Cold War so I guess we
did something I think it's
we do a lot of of intellectualizing and
sometimes we get very powerful people
that sit with us and slow us down
I feel my the back of my head and my
neck getting longer and this is so good
and I just feel like I'm I'm thinking
myself and opening the crown of my head
to the sky
and just remember how grateful we are
and we all must be for the beautiful
life that we have here
and we can better collaborate and pay
respect
sensation
and building out these next iterations
of technologies is very important yeah
you love me very briefly make two points
then I'd love to share the first point
is simply that if you took a dictionary
and you replace all those substituted
each word for a scrambled piece of
gibberish just by looking at the
relationships of those pieces of
gibberish we could pretty accurately
reconstruct the original dictionary even
if you screwed up the word order in
relationships you could get away with it
and this reflects that things are
defined by what they relate to in a very
fundamental way and a related point is
that this is really the insight that a
lot of the deep learning for natural
language processing techniques hinge on
which is the fact that you can just look
at a window around the world like look
at what words are near another word and
figure out its identity by those
relationships and even if you don't have
them labeled there's a lot of incredibly
meekness based on it so what is this
cognition about what isn't under what is
knowing something really what is
thinking about something it is having in
your head maybe your heart too but you
have it if you see all the other things
it evokes the other images it evokes
maybe even the bodily sensations or
emotions it evokes and the same thing
could be a different thing to different
people because they have different
relationships to that thing other things
are pretty often similar the number
three no matter what three objects to
the threes conflict it does not do
I don't know what is the
concept of
meditation practice or yoga I vote for
different people one person might think
it's like oh it's an exercise class
another person is like okay it's this
philosophical system about releasing
unnecessarily held tension in my mind
and resolving conflict in my mind and
the physical thing is only a tool for it
and in each of these cases you can
summon a web around the concept of yoga
for you can summon a web like all the
related concepts and that's its
definition to you ultimately and it's a
bunch of images and stuff like that and
what's interesting is when you tell a
researcher an idea it sparks a different
web of connections and every researcher
or a problem that you're trying to solve
it's about two different set of ideas
and connections and it's because we have
this diversity of sparks in our brains
when you are exposed to an idea that
multiple people working on problems can
you solve different pieces of the
problems the coolest example of this by
the way I think is Project polymath by
Tim Gower's
who is a Cambridge professor and Fields
medalist and on his wordpress blog he
started an amazing thing which is it's
like yo that's very food these theorems
I don't know I do it in the comment
section on his wordpress blog people
posted solutions to them as in little
pieces of it and together they've proved
some things that no one else's
previously they disappeared and I think
there's clearly a huge opportunity to
make better tools for this than a
wordpress blog and actually brings me to
I can share what I'm trying to go she
wants you
cool should I grab that laptop or either
well yep so there's a lot of problems
that all really necessitated the
creation the same tool and one of the
first problems that I started out caring
about is brainstorming hackathon ideas
and
brainstorm II yeah yeah and so I started
out with the Google document hackathon
projects jacob cold net it's
collaborative you can post your
hackathon ideas if you want to share
them or come onto my lips by the way
yes please yes yes yeah so looking at my
screen here this is the map of hackathon
ideas and so how did this start you know
this is you explain to us thought
streaming is a paradigm of taking notes
it's this Harrod I'm of taking what
we're being shown so by the way just
quick thing to avoid contingent thoughts
doing is to paradigm of taking notes
it's not like the name of our company or
anything like that it's just it's
thought hey let's that's not spend too
much time with us okay
bow streaming is just my name for how I
take notes and it doesn't relate to a
tool or anything but you can build
better tools for thoughts to me anyone
could build this yeah so those things it
and then idea flow is my company and we
build tools one of the tools as a tool
for thoughts streaming and it all
interlinked with our general graphic
creation and information manipulation
engine which has a use case that I think
can illustrate something kind of pretty
in front of us
which is about brainstorming ideas for
hackathons and so
it does
except it's two-dimensional much more
usable yes and it's also you can add to
it that's the important thing
this is very interesting I feel as
though Monty's bringing this up because
I think there's an extremely interesting
there's something about that two
dimensionality and how it gets still
very easily catalogued and parcel that I
think it makes sense and we can probably
interesting now seeing it finally in
place is very cool for me and I hope for
you guys that are watching this as well
joining us we'd love to hear your
thoughts below
oh yeah no I had a quick idea on the
2-dimensional thing which was
2-dimensional a two-dimensional map you
have the most space to display things
and the most ways in which different
things can connect because in one
dimensional a thing can only connect to
the next thing or the previous thing
it'll list in 2d things can connect to
an arbitrary number of things through
the sides but you solve the problem that
you have in 3d of things getting in the
way of each other I think that's yeah
that was probably exactly your gripe
when the galaxy was like you just have
all this stuff in front of you and since
our vision is two-dimensional you end up
seeing it as 2d anyway but you're just
missing most of the information I'm
gonna organize data into three
dimensions I have to have I have to be
in like a virtual reality yeah like my
HTC vive where I can walk around the
room and and look around things because
I can't deal with it on a 2d screen and
I don't want to I mean honestly like
it's it's yeah this is a really whole
lot about human cognition and perception
and you know like if what you're trying
to do is convey emotion I think like I
think 3d often like think about the
difference we were watching a play on
stage versus watching a film there's
very different mediums I you know
there's something there's something very
human about seeing people on a stage and
moving around in front of you maybe that
really it's maybe not good
you know having a three-dimensional like
a galaxy on a 2d screen and seeing the
things getting in the way of each other
yeah one of the things there's a couple
things one of the things you know you
can show a multi-dimensional space in
two dimensions without too much trouble
because you know a two dimensions it's
not necessarily just a graph where
you've got you know you've got price and
quantity a demand curve right so it's
not necessarily your two dimensional
space does not just not necessarily just
an x and a y axis right like if you look
at what you were just showing on Jacobs
screen the idea flow you look at idea
flow right this is this is not organized
into a this is not organized into two
dimensions I mean each one of these
lines in this sense is a dimension or
maybe the groups are right like yeah now
it's very hard to make it's very hard to
make sense of that in some ways but I
mean actually here's here's a
controversial possibly question for you
Jake yeah haven't we did all this stuff
that we're talking about in 2d organizer
did we just we just have we just
reinvented mind maps I mean that's like
a technology and a tool it's been around
forever
what's different that's a great question
and so basically mind maps okay firstly
funny person and historical note I
remember being very dismissive of my
mouth very a distinctly remember I was
in a science fair in high school and I
was doing some like thermodynamics
research blahblahblah
and I saw a project that I had qualified
for the Greater San Diego Science Fair
and it was on like do you mind laughs
help you with my first up better than
not the things I like I can't believe
that even gotten to science fair I can't
even believe was accepted in the sensory
to be judged it's like such a such a
project and it wasn't um like I don't
think it was like ridiculously
well-executed project but it also helped
me first I mean I just was like totally
blind to the fact that that when you
have a 2d linking medium it allows you
to fundamentally capture different kinds
of things than in a in a one-dimensional
immediately you can see how things are
connected that said might not as they
originally proposed while they did have
links as a secondary characteristic
they're primarily advertised and
primarily described as like oh man
there's gonna be a tree structure but
it's just you know graph and because
it's visual like our brains are better
dealing with that and you know this I
was I'm not actually looking a lot I'm
not even a lot of memory palaces I
actually believe a lot more in thinking
visually but back then I was like all it
is the same data in a bullet view in a
you know tree format that's useless but
the truth is that how my Nexus is the
linkages and thing is all the mind
mapping software that you find out there
like you can get mind Meister's or
whatever it's hierarchical and because
it's hierarchical you really can't do
this whole reflow the layout thing and
you see what clusters naturally emerge
which is the action that I wanted all
right well the other thing just just a
really simple observation I have is you
know is a mind map if a mind map is
basically just like an outline in a
two-dimensional form is it not just a
collection of a linear a collection of
linear collections right like if I have
a point if I have a point and it's got
you know five sub points those are just
that's just that's just the linear
well I'm building off of that it's not
actually the same thing yeah and what's
interesting though is you were saying
like what makes this concept new and my
thinking my thinking about my response
to that would be like it would be the
transformation of something that see
inherently linear ie like a notepad that
you write from top to bottom into
something that you parse out into
something that looks 2d and looks like a
diagram and maybe that's a doable task
specifically because diagrams are linear
in some sense I guess and that like you
could kind of write them out that way so
it's almost like these these concepts
flip back and forth between each other
like it's interesting like you know
think about outlines why did we ever
learn as kids to do to write outlines
yeah it's because that's how you get
that's how you organize your thoughts to
write a paper and a paper is like the
most linear thing ever right like this
looks like one of my good friends I
submitted her like undergraduate honors
thesis or whatever it was at Stanford
and comparative literature as a giant
mind map with a lot of labeled edges and
she's like you know what look if I
confess this to any linear format it's
gonna lose a lot of information if you
really want to understand this you
should do this and I'll guide you
through how to read it and I think
that's super cool so that's really cool
but that's not your traditional mind map
that's something that is you know mind
map plus plus it's more like what we're
doing here and one very cool thing is
our thing has wormholes in it so she'd
show my screen for a second
intelligence push is that I think with a
pretty high degree of confidence that we
are gonna start visualizing data only in
the three-dimensional spaces that were
lonely we're gonna be engaging it with
our voices we're gonna be engaging and
by actually moving in with our still we
might want to be 2d though even though
in my case but I mean I've got a larger
comments on that you have a lot of
interesting because yeah because I'm
Laird of 2d things argue really useful
luckily there's 2d things that's very
interesting layers that's so cool
because I've been spending a lot of time
in the visioning premiere and all these
tools in a 3d space that I can engage
with voice and with spatial intelligence
movement rather than the meat sticks
yeah and I totally I think there's some
cool 3d things you could do as well
I mean I personally was really just into
like visualizing the sweep of human
activity in many layers like at the
bottom layer you've got like all the
problems that people have you got
clusters are really like let's just look
at Silicon Valley or the Bay Area it's
like I had this vision once after a long
Qigong practice session of like the
sweep of human activity and I was
imagining okay if I really like like it
was like my question that sort of
existential questions what the heck is
going on here and I somehow found it
satisfying to answer the question
literally is like literally what is
going on here what are people doing
around here and so I was like where am I
in the bay and the problems they're
complaining about stuff like that so I
had this it's like a vision which is
really beautiful at the time to me of
like a bunch of at the bottom there's
like a bunch of problems with just
observations and problems and sometimes
people notice they all the same problems
with a cluster together and form groups
are the same problem and then sometimes
when there's a group of people are on
the same problem they come with an idea
of many ideas and that's sort of on the
next level standing in front you can see
like that
the ideas that came out of these
clusters of problems that says ok that's
what's gonna cool and then I was like
okay if you look at that level then is
that clusters of ideas
yeah and a lot of the ideas connect to
each other of course there's cross level
connections as well but I like to layer
it out separately and then you go up to
the next love and you get like
categories of ideas keep these ideas
from questioning their categories and
then maybe there's categories from
categories and then you start also from
the top down if you like okay so like
what are we actually doing here like
what are we actually trying to achieve
as a society and it's like you know like
I'm some level like we're all really
trying to build like Moore's government
trying to achieve they I heard a joke if
Pro is the opposite of con does that
mean that Congress is the opposite of
progress yeah I was like okay what if
what if you actually yes and this is
actually a deeper grab a whole bunch of
research on government tech not examples
so so let me let me the table that for a
second but let me finish the one point
is I come the top-down like if you
really map out what society's trying to
achieve so this is like the bottom up
piece of evasion that explains a second
ago and then like categories of ideas
and the meta categories like that
and then if you cert from the top it's
kind of like okay what a society trying
to achieve and you're like okay well
really like release government in the
theoretical world is thank to really
building utopia not in the dystopian
sense of utopia but like in the actual
like positive
wiebe and underneath that you've got
lots of subcategories that you could
break that down into like you could say
health happiness prosperity tranquility
all these very high-level values many
other values those are like the next
level down and then next level down from
that you've got like okay like what is
like tranquility look like and part of
it is peace of mind and part of peace of
mind is like no crime and like says zero
crime goes down and if you start these
like utopian maps from the top and then
you start these like maps of what's
actually happening from the bottom
eventually you can start by categorizing
all actions that people are taking and
seeing how they map on to these
high-level goals and either they're
bringing these goals forward are they
not and it started with the progress
bars that I could show off at some point
but anyway the question is when you
start to do something it's gonna have a
complex effect some positive some
negative and a net on the net are we
really moving ourselves towards these
goals they want to achieve at a high
level and my personal belief is very
optimistic it's just like if we really
systematically got coordinator human
actions we could like lickety-split
achieve basically everyone's basic needs
being met and the question is how do we
build tools when we build cultural tools
cultural engineering is just as
important that really enable us to go
like get together and all get more by
working less it actually just as a quick
side comics and remembering it right now
one concept that really attracts me is
this idea of building labor-saving
devices like for me as a technologist
this just means I'm lazy as heck and it
just means that it one more time for
create and not just that it's like I
enjoy the active building tools that
automate a repetitive task
I don't enjoy doing repetitive tasks
like I was the nerd who in middle school
when I was given a word search for
homework spent twelve hours writing a
program to solve word searches it was a
doozy of a word search I tell you and
the word search was like to learn your
vocab
stuff like that it was a terribly learn
vocabulary but if that was fun program
to write anyway I love building these
automated tools and then my point is the
point is to build the labor-saving
devices not labour creating devices and
the the issue with like this technology
that addicts us and these walled gardens
between different tools and stuff like
that like the fact that you can't see
your emails and your LinkedIn feed and
your Facebook feed and you can't
remember which tools searching because
of all these like artificial walled
garden studios the data solves these our
labor creating devices that are the or
or various to labor saving devices at
least their barriers to labor saving
device their barriers to and thank God
email was like I still on the pattern of
a relic from the old days when people
actually had utopian aspirations because
like you know how all the chat plant
stuff down the API is terrifying me like
what if like you couldn't send emails to
people who weren't on Gmail or if you
could only send emails to people on
Gmail not on yeah like that's what the
chapter situation is like right now and
that yeah so that's a point instead of
the Facebook message to someone on
LinkedIn can send Instagram yeah yeah
this is a major problem because
and as a paradigmatic point here that's
super interesting here is like really
the devices that we have they aren't
really on our side they're close to
being on the company company side than
being on our side the devices were
really on our side it would be easy to
write an iPhone app that's a meta chat
app or something like that but it's
actually really hard to do that right
now you got to grapple with all kinds of
restrictions but really there should be
this layer between like those companies
apps and it's like okay you've got your
tool that processes stuff for you and
like maybe autocompletes where you're
gonna say so you know type as much or
this goes into what I was talking about
with earlier with tcp/ip and lessons
from you know the kind of the network
side I want what do I want as a you know
in a write a user story around it like
as a human being I want to communicate
with other human beings in a way that is
you know most appropriate to the
communication I am intending to send and
so you know I would love to be able to
just talk into my phone and say hey Siri
send an important message to Jacob Cole
about need to change the time of our
meeting this afternoon and have her
figure out based on what what she knows
about Jacob Cole and what you pay
attention to and if this is an important
message okay it's gonna send it as a
text or it's gonna send it to you on
facebook messenger because you use
Facebook or whatever like I shouldn't
have to know what your preferences are
that should be built into the protocol
in the protocol err right like Apple
which obviously isn't full of Engineers
like you're running Apple I would
probably not be if I was running Apple
or Google or LinkedIn or Facebook the
one thing I would address would be
context as the context is like the most
important thing in our world it's who do
you know and how do you get in touch
with contacts contacts if you look at
Google look at the Google suite of apps
contacts is a is a redheaded stepchild
of Gmail it's not even a top-level app
in the universe of Google and I've
talked about this with like some very
high up people at Google and they're
just like
yeah you know but guys this not gold
it's a gold mine it is a gold mines yes
I mean this is the way Microsoft can
actually kill Google if Microsoft
actually put somebody visionary in
charge of LinkedIn and figured out what
LinkedIn is actually about is human
connection and not selling you
recruiting like yeah well I think about
how many of them I can discuss anyway
but anyway let's talk about wormholes
for a second all right so - yep sure my
screen so you guys check this out here's
an idea that someone proposed which was
actually a real hackathon project at Cal
hacks yeah so one person is like yo
build an eye-tracking heat map from your
webcam that's a cool thing and that
really says am for vision it's just like
uses an electro ocula gram to look at
what you're gazing at and identifies
that thing could be useful for people
with impaired vision especially but
anyway is it cool really well done
hackathon project but now let's talk
about a wormhole it's like okay I
remember I saw a project somewhere else
in this map which is Shazam for plants I
think it's like right a person they say
Shazam for plants and look at that there
it is that is oh and look at I also
found shows em for TV that's kind of
cool hangout live let's let's let's see
yep and let's add a couple connections
to its absence am for plants is a
connection bloom it was just right over
there so
and do you call us a knowledge graph
called an idea graph because in
knowledge graph is what Google is doing
and ideas are this isn't knowledge this
is like a frickin and it's not a book
searching it's about as I'm composing
but that's not even here that's not even
the important thing the important thing
here is I'm just going along making a
mind map of things manually it augments
my intelligence passively as I do it and
so like she them for TV that's connected
and we can do some natural way of
crossing and suggest connections it's
just pretty powerful so you don't even
have to write manually I think I think
the whole idea of being just a simple
intelligence augmentation notebook is
best illustrated over here so I say Jack
Bravo he spends a type Japan yin and you
know Jack Bravo studied at Stanford so
I'm gonna say I studied at Stanford
no no this is our this is our our
note-taking interface on the computer
yeah and so you click on on Stanford and
you know what that turned blue and an
auto completed so that obviously the
system knows something about Stanford
they click on Stanford and wallah and it
was a ton about Stanford and it just
surfaced this as I was typing like a
normal person
that has a previous a way that you
you've added Stanford s kind of look a
Lego piece and then Stanford every time
someone types Stanford then the Lego
piece populates in a drop-down option so
they can go and drop that down is that
exactly and so I mean you can expand
people indefinitely as well like for
instance is one of our customers Silicon
Valley Bank and this is how steep they
apparently the chief of staff there yeah
yeah and so this is he apparently
Silicon Valley Bank has this guy Dave
Koch back who's connected Doug Engelbart
he was intellectual raffle is Marvin
Minsky and yeah like we are you
connected to any of these people that
were looking at right here on the screen
multi Xerox PARC Doug Engelbart JCR
Licklider Alan Kay I don't know actually
this is a kind of cool thing I mean so
so what we could do is let's let's just
do this it's kind of cool I can say well
it's just let's just pivot around Monte
for a second
so yeah we're trying to build me the the
homepage this could be it these two
facts about me that's my entire yeah
well what's kind of cool is like for
instance okay so let's just so what
what's the name of this podcast going to
be well the stimulation series right
simulation series human AI hybrid
podcast okay see that and then it'd be
like okay and so I'm gonna call it's a
participant of simulation to his human
hybrid podcast now participant Jack
Botha Monte Kozma Jacob Cole and how do
you spell your home you know okay boom
you know I just got to tell you maybe
it's the Burning Man in you but you
wrote party pants party pants party
pants I love my party pants at home yes
sorry particpants participant yeah well
the cool thing is by the way the cool
thing is but intelligently like if you
yourself figure out the relationship
yeah parties particular out so you see
that it just pivoted and it detected
that I have the same relationship thank
you very much okay so I type that in
it's like Alan zakian mom our friends
with Alex
kei-chan we click on Alex kitchen you
can see like many things that Alex is
connected to it the Alex Kate you in the
Mafia and if a pivot around the Alex
kitchen mafia is based on your
repository
yep and this is my team and my is
collective brain here it just allows me
to just start typing and take notes and
oops if my teammate took notes on it
I just summon all their notes instantly
surely you will be able to we're gonna
have many levels of a graph some are
public some are private we're focused on
doing this for enterprise internally
right now and we're working hard to get
to a place where you can make a public
version which is gonna make it
exponentially better for everybody just
just follow up on that enterprise using
this today what is it you like what are
the use cases where people come to you
and say I want to give you piles of
money so that I can use this what are
they what is the problem it's solving
for them well there's a couple problems
the first problem is it openly comes
down to the
connecting people who should be
connected problem yeah and it can either
happen internally or externally so for
instance some large corporations
especially those that have acquired lots
of other companies have many redundant
teams and many redundant projects going
on and they want to deduplicate these on
the other side certain investment
research arms like when I can talk about
a Silicon Valley Bank they have a vested
interest in all of the companies in
there who banking with them doing really
well so they want to connect them with
each other and the other resources that
are relevant so they not caught the
whole startup ecosystem they understand
who the key influencers are they can see
on the map who because they can see
these people are connected all the
high-performing companies and then they
can find also when there are synergies
between projects at different other
customers are working on lastly if you
want to understand like a new industry
such as like that one one kind of cool
one is autonomous driving that we've
made a map of over here you you can
really quickly
understand it in Satomi Eagles you can
really quickly understand like what are
the key component parts even if you knew
nothing about the industry if I go into
guidance systems go into sensors over
here and have you built out all this
data or did you get this from somewhere
it's human ai ai hybrid constructed so
we can pull it from many different
sources such as scraping the web reading
internal documents that are unstructured
or structured than humans can review it
and make sure it's all in a curated
format but there's is a pretty awesome
knowledge graph which you can also
always add to it it only takes a couple
people who are working really hard to
make an awesome map that's that's very
informative to a lot of other people
it's how companies want to pay the big
bucks for this because they want to make
the connections to the right people and
the right organizations that they need
to advance their innovation and
departments yeah yeah it's either
because they want to do this internally
or because they want to do this internal
to their company or they want to do an
external in the world and so just to
finish this example real quick this is
kind of kind of nifty so Thomas vehicles
industry like who knows what goes into
this thing unless you're an expert well
guidance systems sensors sensors include
cameras and radar and lidar and what the
heck is lidar if you do that it's like
Oh follow diodes make lidar over here
here's a couple companies that make
photo diodes like these are all going to
be impacted by the growth of the
autonomous vehicles industry well the
important thing is is it's what you
really do in your brain after you do all
that Wikipedia researching and the thing
is if we want to prevent people from
boiling the ocean twice so basically if
one person has spent hours learning
about industry and they create this map
in their brain they should be able to
share it and then the next person in the
company who wants to go I spend time
parsing information and synthesizing it
and then I go live and I talk about it
because at least then taking that
taking your cognition you're exporting
external iced yeah you're externalizing
media cognition I'm externalizing parts
of my mental lattice little bit worried
wait I work with the other collections a
good word
hashtag quote hashtag phrase by the way
I just say this because I know in the
future my audio parsing script will be
able to find hashtags women in my speech
so I say hashtag phrase I'll be able to
find it again in the future yeah just
you just need to build an Alexa app
interface yeah I mean it's an you know
the idea map we keep throwing around but
it it's kind of like a map I mean one of
the things that you get looking at
autonomous vehicles this way an idea
flow that you don't get as readily
reading a bunch of articles on Wikipedia
or ever you go to find them or google
searching about it is it's like the
difference between if I'm gonna go to
Paris right
I can I can look at a map of the city if
I'm going to Paris I can look at a map
of the city you know I'm gonna have a
very different understanding of Paris
looking at a map of a city versus just
showing up and walking around right yeah
and I get a sense of the whole in the
parts and how do they relate to each
other and then you know and then I could
go read a guide book and I can go deep
and really learn a lot or I can go visit
the city itself but those are all very
different and much more intense focused
deep activities and if what I want to do
is get a sense of the whole this is the
way you have to do it otherwise you
could spend you know 20 years exploring
Paris
interesting very ancient way of
understanding this is how someone took
months or years of their life to write a
book with someone else reads it in 18
hours yeah yeah so okay so let's let's
play on this on this example you want
you know if I go and I build up this
mental lattice around vary around an
edge of knowledge and I synthesize it in
disseminated in really relatable ways to
the general audiences of people then
they go and watch this period of that I
took hours and hours to synthesize down
so maybe have 20 30 minutes a video then
we're asking the audience to be able to
somehow engage with this piece of
content in some other way in the best
way I know YouTube comments and that's a
joke there needs to be a different way
for the community to be able to build on
this platform one of the things that we
deal with in community building I guess
we aim to figure out better ways for the
people that are a part of the
subscribership of a channel like
simulation to be able to talk to each
other about the content that they are
watching and to be able to link up with
each other via email or via chats you
know the exact cetera yeah look video is
I mean I used to I was the CEO oh and I
ran fandora first Netflix competitors
and we're dealing with video video is a
really challenging content it's linear
it's it's experienced you know in
sequence and it's very very challenging
it's if you want to sit back and just
take it in it's great but but it is a
very very high I guess you'd call it
it's very demanding it demands a lot of
attention to actually get something out
of it and if what I really want is to
like take our whole conversation and
find the part that was about
whatever Thinking Machines and metaweb
and really like go deep on that I can't
do it you know I really can't do that
what I need is I need like a two
dimensional idea flow map of the video
that allows me to go there to listen to
that part and then have a conversation
with people in the context that's
created by the map yeah but the problem
there is that like but if but if what I
want to do is actually engage with
another member of the audience or with
the or was one of us about that subject
there's no way for us to organize that
conversation and have it in a coherent
way yes in a youtube comment I mean no
it's not gonna work because YouTube
comments also yes straight linear
I'm just starting to map out some notes
from this conversation and it's really
interesting actually
so these notes aren't aren't super duper
ambitious and you know that the reason
is is because my purpose here with these
notes is actually different than
transcribing the conversation
thank you for transcribing the
conversation we could also do it in a
format like this and we could just show
the branches and flows and stuff and
he's also show the interconnections back
and maybe I should actually type it up
and do it but it would be so sweet if we
could have that in real time on the show
like like what but let's just let's just
actually get like one Brenda stop right
there we've been for the longest time
talking about how important it is for
the guest that is on the show and the
hosts that are having a nuanced
discourse to also have a simultaneous
knowledge graph being built out
simultaneous
yeah that the viewership can engage with
one moment and then then not only are
they watching this knowledge gap they're
engaging with it you can see the key
points being made along the way and you
can reference it along the way remember
in the first talk about that there are
takeaways which is the biggest thing
that people are asking for nowadays is
what is to take away after your talk
what is it take away after the election
what is it take away after this meeting
bla bla bla bla bla well guess what the
end every single one of these dialogues
we will have knowledge graph plus main
takeaways at the end of the episode so
we have to follow a discourse model that
thought that runs with the knowledge
graph and in the action items and I'm
really passionate about building that
into the show and making that popular in
this is a problem you look at MOOC
debates you'll get intelligence squared
debate you want to get these things on
two stages under 50,000 see sports
stadium stages which is where we want to
take intellectual discourse at the
global level the way to get there is by
well add a lot of a lot of big
conferences a couple of times like at
CES I think you know you have you know
giant can't speaker they'll have an
artist with a giant piece of paper who
draws and it's just a car it's a cartoon
and they try to capture it's
two-dimensional right it's interesting
and you've got pictures and a lot of the
ideas end up being represented now I
don't know if they're doing that with
any sense of like where it's going or if
they're completely improving that as
they go but that's the only thing that
even resembles that that I've seen I
mean I mean
these are this good stuff is better you
gonna say anything better than what I
was gonna say so please um okay so I
want to share something kind of cool is
one of my friends suddenly has it his
eyes open to the world me he tried an
exercise which is to have a conversation
with something on paper oh yes that was
exercise bro you know it's even easier
than that all you need to do is try to
have a conversation with someone as if
you're both mute and you have to write
on paper to communicate with each other
because then you automatically become
more common
well not that's not the point it's not
the point it's all it's an interesting
point though it is an easy point but
that's not all the point you just the
point is that it starts to feel really
unnatural really quickly to just have
like a chat stream of dialogue instead
it's like no we're branching over here
so you go to the side and when you start
branching then you write it on that side
and then it's like okay we're gonna go
back to the main branch and you you go
back to the main branch and if anyone oh
this is so awesome because it's just
like this conversation has had you know
this may be this main aspect of the flow
but then all these yeah and we branched
in physically represented and you just
visit view it's just what happens like
it's so I think it's so unnatural to
have a chat dialogue when you start
writing on paper and the only reason
that are chapped dialogues like chapter
logs is because the medium of chat is
are like in this linear format it's cuz
the medium of chat does not allow us to
do this branching thing huh why doesn't
the medium of check if they're faster
it's been so long we've had over a
decade now 15 years plus to evolve this
out
more branch are you talking about the
medium of like like text messages are
like literal in person conversations
technics okay
I mean it's true of in-person
conversations that it's like there's an
inherent limitation in that technology
that we have which is our mouths smells
like represent information that way and
right you're limited by their like
brains of everyone involved to actually
keep track but we have a great mom I
mean in just this is just the throw the
scent I mean in any single threaded
computational system if you're using a
using like a decent programming language
like Lisp for example which is what I
would use you've got the idea of stack
frames and lexical closures and like we
do that in our conversations we don't
really think about it that way but
that's what we do and if we actually
were good about if we were actually
really good about you know about stack
frames and stack maintenance and garbage
collection our conversations would
probably be a lot more effective but
it's hard to do that because we're
relying on our own crappy memories our
brains but our memory is limp like our
creativity and infinite burn memory is
limited this is so seven we can enter
memory and then think bigger thoughts
and do bigger things I've been arguing
to memory in my thought stream right now
I'm keeping track of the conversational
staff which has more points on it but
let's not even get there it would be a
fun exercise actually it will be a fun
exercise I don't know if I'm gonna do it
but maybe maybe someone out there and
listener land would do it to create like
the stack frame flow of this
conversation and just see what we can
learn from that
I mean fascinating to see like just the
idea that we were talking about this and
then that led to this and then we led to
this and did we ever get back we can use
AI to transcribe it to begin with which
is like fright this frightening leader
in transcription now it's ridiculously
good and I highly recommend downloading
it and just using it to transcribe all
kinds of conversations but like as a
very heavy voice recognition user i'm
distinctly impressed by it and it works
even if your phones on the table then
you have to manually make it into the
tree / ground
into the tree sauce draft but then at
least we have this vodcast that ends up
being completely branched out ya know
this is the first step in showing other
people that this is the way that we want
to explore synthesizing the complex and
nuanced conversation into knowledge
graphs Chrissy small crises no I don't
actually speakers look good exit I thank
you I was just I was just dying to go to
do this and actually real quick can we
solicit viewers to see if anyone wants
to take notes on this conversation and
help us do transcribing it in general
like do you think we could solicit see
if maybe someone listening real-time
would be interested in being our
transcriber like someone who types
really fast or maybe is a court reporter
even but you just typed hella fast can
like take notes on what we're doing that
is likely caliber of the current
viewership this is not the Joe Rogan
experience so we do not have
a bunch of them are really fast words
per minute Tigers that they can do that
we can speak to our future viewers we
can speak to the future in your so if
there are people that want to to be
doing that then you can the email the
email addresses in is in the in the bio
simulation series at gmail.com just send
us well I'm inspired by one of your
previous ideas just a link to thread
back that you had a you have one of your
idea flow diagrams you're showing about
hackathon ideas and you know what you do
you just take this take this
conversation take all the data from it
the audio the video whatever the
transcription if we can you know massage
one up and run a hackathon let's run a
hackathon around it see what tools we
can create that create a map a visual
map two-dimensional mat whatever it is
look what ideas do people come up with
and use this as the input wouldn't it be
fun right because if you can sponsor a
hackathon around that you get a bunch of
brilliant people in the room to take
this and see what you can do with it
then you can start to generalize
especially if we make the assumption
that this serves as a good sort of
poster child for a like intellectual
conversation that follows some sort of
framework of like what we were talking
about with going up the stack and then
down the stack again if we have that
structure to this conversation then
maybe that makes it an easier like
almost an easier and a flatter we get to
because he would use this on his podcast
exactly the kind of coverage we just get
him to fund it from the fun little
hackathon and will do it also wants to
help to comics first comment is if
anyone's halfway on related stuff please
hit me up at jacob at idea flow do and
actually people who are like good at
javascript or good at iOS especially but
all kinds of stuff i want to work with
me
also we're hiring and that's okay that
time that's a good plug that's Jacob at
idea flow da I hope so definitely do
follow yeah and there's not very least
let's hack down hackathon projects like
look like the world is about a hackathon
we have poor hackers who have poor
treatment on it and that's Mike I think
the future of work will what is it
hashtag phrase yes now it'll be picked
up in all posterity and so yeah the
truth is I think like all that we call
work these days could come there's a
famous book which is finally happy
person and you'll find the project and
hashtag cool yeah this is distance
high-five distance I imagine you could
just search through and say every time
you say the hashtag quote ever in your
life then it was just like I love all
those things my life sounds so amazing
in comparison to what it's like right
now see what I'm saying this this 3000
plus note-taker if if it was just
possible to just these things are
listening to us anyways
why don't they just do their recording
yeah give me this long as we're gonna
long as the NSA is gonna listen to us
they might as well supply system useful
data
you got a whisper iterative here
absolutely so so why not cuz that
actually does make a lot of sense for
making our lives better so interesting
to pull like everything neuroscience
everything all these great articles all
these great leaders across the world and
you could even search you know you could
even do is do some really cool
post-processing and whenever it hears
you talking with like a particularly
peaceful or particularly excited tone of
voice you can bring up all the times
you've had a very peaceful tone of voice
and then it would understand the context
previously and I mean this is a brave
new world here guys and it's amazing
actually I don't even like using that
phrasing but it really is this an
awesome future that we can live in this
super futuristic future it's way cooler
than most of the Syfy's imaginations of
teacher yeah and well I actually want to
make just pop on one point or something
you said or we just alluded to earlier
just to touch back on something that
there is you know this is all nice and
you can apply it to you know academic
research and you know doing better and
all it is worth pointing out to the you
know the VCS and investors out there
there is a lot of value to be created I
mean just the tools just for example
like just the tools that you know the
business processes I created and the
tools that we used in the the PNG
Gillette deal we saved just by doing
that on the entire legal fees for the
you know the 50 billion dollar merger we
save 15% of the total legal bill and
this is the kind of promise that is out
there you know I'm working now in the
realm of construction and you know we're
talking about you know billion
dollar-plus
projects you think about what it what is
going on in our world we're building
these massive data centers all over the
world we're building 5g networks we're
building massive massive oil and gas
energy projects we're building wind
farms I mean all these things are they
have a lot of zeros on them and you know
constructions the only industry that
had declining productivity over the last
twenty to thirty years it's nuts that's
another whole story but no but it has
something to do with claims and has
something to do with it's actually
really hard to manage large projects
it's really really hard and oh and many
of the tools that have been developed
are actually counterproductive but what
happens this is the hybrid this is this
is like well you know and and you know
it's just like I mean who does waterfall
code development anymore right but
that's a lot of the way these projects
that run it's essentially the same thing
and you know so some of this is you know
applying agile a lot of it is applying
machine learning because there's so many
you know you're solving a multi thousand
dimensional problem so the opportunity
to create value by taking this kind of
hybrid man-machine approach part of it
is on knowledge but part of it is also
just sort of traditional machine
learning stuff
let's test all the options and see what
actually performs so all these different
realms there's just massive massive
value to be created and you know that
that that improves our world in so many
ways right
we value various and making the world
better also people actually I still look
still trying to wrap my mind around how
many of these mergers and acquisitions
happen all the time around the world
where if they just had better tools to
be ok so closing yes I got a few quick
comments yeah so first on the previous
topic so if we didn't talk about these
conversations you know my experience
maybe your experience too they have a
lot of very repetitive conversations and
I watched people who discover and
rediscovering the same thing over and
over again in conversation like this
yeah and what I would love to do is
create not just a map of our
conversation but enough of all these
conversations that are happening in the
world and find the overlapping graphs of
conversations yeah that's yeah
absolutely and like then maybe even fast
forward to the end no I don't think
that's the right solution here but what
the point is is to understand that
there's a lot of things that are
repeating themselves you can build on
top of exact because what you do is when
you when you take and you see a
conversation like the one that we have
here tonight and then we we see the
similarities with what we talked about
along so many other of these knowledge
collective learning
intelligence style conversations that
are happening we see the overlaps then
we can build on the overlaps moving
forward because it seems like so many
people care about that there's probably
someone literally on YouTube who's had a
conversation it's very very pertinent to
what we're doing here what we're talking
about here and maybe has even covered
some of the same points and I would love
to see that overlapping conversation and
we just collaboratively by having all
this conversation isn't in the world but
we're all doing is contributing to that
knowledge grout to that map that giant
map of conversation space of all
conversations that have been had we are
boldly pushing that bubble of
conversation space larger and larger and
so okay
another point real quick you know
another point is an action item
all right even before the action of them
one thing yeah so for if I had to like
pointed a field that VCS are not looking
into enough right now I would also say
intelligence amplification this is a
phrase that you should look up you
should also look up on Wikipedia Doug
Engelbart and look at his guiding
philosophy there's the most awesome
result of an existential crisis forever
and that guy's my intellectual hero
what's the white voices he was the
inventor of the mouse among many other
things but the father of the field of
intelligence amplification or an ia I
mean okay so very quick overview here
the idea since humans were pre humans is
like your entire part of our thing is we
make tools and I feel very much south I
feel very satisfied being a tool maker
and Doug Engelbart is like yo let's use
these computers to create tools that
augment our ability to manipulate
information just like we've built
incredibly receiving devices to make it
easier to go farm and do all kinds of
physical things and this is contrasted
to at least AI in its original form and
often as its implemented now it's like
yo we're gonna from the top down just
try to make something that will think to
make a machine that will think and is
moving tools and they meet in the middle
some someday yes very interesting so
that would be some of the tools we were
talking about earlier these tools that
help humans with human centric powers
Minsky Engelberg the famous debate about
AI a versus AI and anglers like you but
what would it do for the humans what's
it gonna do for the humans and in
Minsky's like you know if we're lucky
the AI will keep us as pets
so eg is very very interesting so like
there's a there's lots of talk on this
on this front and I want to make a
couple comments you know I think it it
easily cannon some plausible paths to it
that could happen both top-down and the
bottom-up but they're very interesting
but I don't know I don't want to quit
date time they've just made sure all
right
so digitize your consciousness be a part
of the most important if you upload your
consciousness you can make backup copies
and then you can also send it to other
clinics as fast you can send information
but that's a large different discussions
right very exciting stuff but
biologically want to go for anyway lots
of profound insight some meditation
about like where's the south end and the
other begin that will be made super
apparent as a result of all that green
uploading stuff that may happen at some
point but that's a different discussion
future Abdi
the important point here is there are
certain tasks which I find it a
implausible that anything that is in the
current machine learning revolution will
actually be able to perform an example
of these tasks and even if they did it
wouldn't matter is that that would be
interesting it wouldn't really matter
but it's like okay I studied computer
science and English literature and what
I do as anglish literature person is
I'll read a quote gonna be like wow
that's a profound quote like you know
that relates to some quote that I read
hashed I quote and then it relates to
angle brackets some quote from another
book that I read like a long time ago
and it's like speaking of the same truth
and one too wise quote speak of the same
truth this is like an indicator that
something is even deeper going on these
days that gave rise to that that truth
and this is what you read essays about
this is how your at essays this is what
essays are about is finding these deep
linkages between concepts either within
a book or across books and linking them
all together and this would form your
thesis is like what they you know I
didn't realize how profound like like
middle school English class made it
really boring but it knows how profound
reading this type of paragraph essays
the species could be if you actually do
it from that bottom up wait until like
midway through college and just it's
about connecting these insights and
actually uncovering these these things
not about the essay and anyway yeah yeah
so the important point here is like if
you built a machine that could like
understand some profound quote and find
you related quote would be super useful
super interesting but a lot of the
deepest connections are mediated by the
vector of human experience and so like
if you haven't have a certain human
experience there's no way that you're
gonna relate some quote to something
else and that's not a task that even if
it were replaced would would stop humans
from doing it because it's still
fulfilling for us to see these
connections
internally it may help us along that's
the first comment the last comment is
this last moment this is an action item
okay and this is a takeaway hashtag
takeaway it's slightly tangential it
seems but it is actually tangential in
the real sense of tangential meaning
it's key
and this is really actionable why did I
start making this database of ideas why
did this all get started it's because I
saw people around me working on things
that were way suboptimal for them to be
working on in terms of their own
happiness their money-making good for
the world any of these things and right
now there's a lot of low-hanging fruit
ideas that we could just do we could
snap our fingers here in Silicon Valley
and help people in a huge way in all
parts of the world here locally and in a
distant way and all that's lacking is
the connection of the people who can do
execute the ideas the ideas and the
connection people of the people to each
other and the curated database of really
good ideas so what I want to do is begin
a project mapping out many steps here
firstly I wanna make a database of all
the projects going on in the Bay Area
database of all the parts going on at
Stanford I want to make a database of
all the ideas that people have in the
bare yeah all the ideas people have that
say Stanford or anywhere this is just a
starting point I want to then make a
database of all the problems that people
are facing in the bear all the problems
that people are facing at some subset
Stanford is just to show the scope I
chose Stanford as an example it's
nothing special and we have a
representative right here and oh the the
last thing is so I really care about the
world and like I my mom was in the Peace
Corps in Tanzania and I ran at Ella have
found that team students there to work
on projects the students at MIT and the
project they were working on were like
frickin brilliant and they were
low-hanging fruit and they were way more
impactful and many times more
interesting than the kinds of things
that people generally were compact ones
here so I make a database of the ideas
and problems that people are facing and
we invite the readership to contribute
either low hanging fruit ideas that just
need to get implemented that they're
aware of or they want to connect over or
connect to other people over and I want
to invite people to contribute the
problems that they're facing as well and
I may propose that they do it at the
interface of a big Google document
hackathon projects Jacob Colt net just
add the ideas at the top of this thing
put your email down it just literally
add them right here that's this to share
my screen real quick
yeah yep and just just throw the ideas
on this Google document and this will be
the start of a huge repository of really
worthwhile ideas and problems and maybe
we'll be able to connect you with some
relevant people to go work together on
these problems or connect you with ideas
and we got a we gonna do these accidents
these are so crucial we're gonna round
this hackathon also I'm like to make yo
we need a bay area of a project graph
to see how we can
normally we asked questions
maybe we asked you guys what's the most
beautiful
I've been quick answer no I mean for me
if I could just like point out one piece
of technology it is not a piece of
technology it is you know in a
traditional sense but it is the
technology if everything in the world is
practicing Qigong which is like Tai Chi
but really basic like do simple things
where you hold your arms up for five
minutes and with the elbows a little bit
and unkink things just so that you can
imagine that there's like this imaginary
fluid flowing through their shoulders
that are really tight right now you're
actually show these this and lift your
armpits my teacher says imagine they're
Chihuahuas in your armpits and you don't
want to squish them you can really start
to feel this flow in this connection
between your hands and you know I think
if everyone could do 20 minutes of
Qigong like it's very embody sort of
meditation every morning and feel as
good as I do about it and really enjoy
it like I do I can't think of anything
no technology nothing in my life that
would have a bigger impact in the world
that's it
what are you guys most beautiful things
for me I would say switch the inputs but
I would say existence when I thought
about the answer to that question
there's a sort of like philosophical
musing on that which would be like
existence is the thing that creates the
ability to perceive beauty in the first
place so you kind of have to have it as
a prerequisite but it really is the or I
guess I should say consciousness more
than that existence like the fact that
we are here and able to actually like
these arrangements of molecules have
gained the ability to see and understand
other things outside of it and that the
world isn't just like completely you
know a bunch of things hitting each
other but is really like you know all
these people and the
beings who can understand and perceive
stuff I think that's like probably the
most beautiful thing in the world well
it's almost like we are channeling the
forces of nature to go do things that
are I guess it was a deep relationship
between what I said and what you said
which is like becoming aware of energy
not my own and realize that things just
happen inside my mind and outside of my
mind and what where does that even
tender begin
but without my intention and being able
to channel that is what I think
existence is yeah yeah and that's what
computers are - by the ways channeling
the universe's tendency to compute the
next state from the previous anyway I
think for me I would say I was a lot of
problem probable kind of candidates and
the hard part is how to express it I
think I would say that it's the getting
another person and being gotten by them
and one of those aligned there's nothing
that is the most beautiful thing it's
like an extension of who you are when
that happens yeah it's like you're not
just your we were so close to this I
just bigger yeah
alright movie simulation for you massive
arena simulation there's that argument
of like probabilistically we have to be
since like if every you know universe
with intelligent whatever ends up
creating simulations then you have like
a top-level universe and then a chain
downward of like this simulation then
creates this simulation which creates
this simulation and then the number of
simulations you have is vastly larger
than the number of top-level universes
but I don't know I still think probably
not I think the best I think the best
way to find out is to create things so
beautiful that the people who made the
simulation have to talk to us I don't I
don't think so I mean we start to get
into the meta game of well what is a
simulation sometimes I think it is
sometimes I don't I don't think so today
oh man I have it listen accomplishing
one second he doesn't know his kind of
hilarious you answer first real quick
and then I'll go I mean I guess for me
it changes probably every three months
roughly but maybe right now is to just
experience things and think about things
which is like an extremely vague canned
answer but like I think that does
actually like apply to what I've been
trying to do a lot right now when I
think about it especially like since I
just graduated from school but I haven't
like you know funneled myself into a
full-time job yet this seems like a good
time for me to do those sorts of things
I think so
yeah that's been forefront in my mind
I'd say
guiding principle
or driving for us or the driving force
driving for us the driving force I I
mean I love transformation I love making
a difference to you and to you and to
you to the people that I interact with
whether they're my family or my clients
are my girlfriend or whatever maybe my
kids but with this caveat to it that I
want to make a difference to you in what
matters to you in the realm that is
really important to you so that's I
think my god
but that's really important
yes so I'll give the answer that I gave
when I was younger and now my refinement
which I realize it touches that when I
was about 13 my mom asked me this
question while we were walking down the
beach
I said maximise surfing potential
maximize potential to go surfing not
just for me but for all of us
and surfing takes lots of forms a lot of
things you can realize are surfing like
when you surf the waves thoughts that
bubble up in your mind in meditation
that's also forming surfing it's also
about channeling energy not here on and
if you maximize surfing potential this
would entail a lot of things you know
very literally I was thinking it dance
like you know is that really good wave
pools in like the Middle East everywhere
everyone's gonna be surfing and then
they're not gonna be like being
terrorists and that was my my middle
school conception of this whole thing
and you know then I really realized
there's a another several levels on this
and I had to nail one thing
would be too
maximize the flow of love and of Chi
and you got to release a lot of kinks in
the world for that to happen a lot of
stuck places it's realizing that there's
all this unnecessarily hell tension it
really seeing where this is this
unnecessarily tailed help tension get
and you can see how it's to be so much
better and then you release it's just so
satisfying
doesn't matter if it's you or another
person that is what does that even mean
it's just tension and when I connect
people to each other
it's like unlocking that potential in
the world yes and it's it's getting that
boom when I practice she go i unlock the
muscle attention in my mind and in my
body and sometimes even in the world
around me that is restricting the flow
of love and my intention when I help
someone who's having a struggling
emotional time what it really comes down
to is there's this blockage or this this
restriction and I want to unblock that
restriction you work if a couples
therapist goes and helps a couple that
was having a bad time it's really it's
not about what's right and wrong it's
what keeps the love flowing yeah if I
had to generalize I would say all these
things I'm doing or trying to maximize
you know it's always hits them in those
I had these profound states of mind from
the most unusual and unexpected places I
just I suddenly feel like wow this is a
profound moment this is what I was
always trying to to build in and I see
that that love is the thing that allows
you to forgive your when you really feel
that profound state and you're right
there you realize that you know that
this is really like you can suddenly
forgive yourself here 10,000 past
mistake because you realize you know
this thing right how right now this is
the thing that
I spent all my lifetime trying to build
and you no matter what I screwed up on I
just achieved the thing and it doesn't
matter what else happens now
guys I want to thank everyone for for
tuning in I want to this has been crazy
longest show we've done yet thanks
everyone
we appreciate it so much and yeah to 20
crazy cool this has been awesome human
AI hybrid collaboration super
multifaceted it's been a lot of fun guys
talking about this building tools
maximizing humanity's collective and
individual capabilities saving us vast
amounts of cognitively we're gonna
extend our memory in all areas of life
we'd like to love to hear from you all
below we'd love to hear from you in the
comments let us know what your thoughts
were on the episode and go and build the
future everyone go and go ahead and
build these tools that we're talking
about join us in our efforts as we go
and we do things like move forward in
making this hackathon happen making
these better and build your own crews
into the world everyone much loves we
greatly appreciate it yes and submit
that list of ideas and problems submit
the list of ideas and problems and
that's that's it Monty
much love thanks everyone
we really appreciate it and we'll see
you soon please keep supporting artists
and entrepreneurs